today's product let companies
distinguish themselves not just on their
products but also how they monetize them
once a product launches into the market
its success is dependent on a robust
monetization strategy that creates
sustainable profits over time in midst
market changes and consumer behavior
with udacity z' new monetization
strategy course from the upcoming growth
product manager name and degree program
you'll learn how to turn products into
businesses monetization is the oxygen
that makes a business's growth
profitable in this course you will learn
a set of principles that guide the
selection of markets in which you play
the persona of buyers that you target
and the outreach channels through which
you reach out to potential customers
growth product managers need a deep
flexible and comprehensive analytical
skill set that covers the entire funnel
from customer acquisition to
monetization in this course you'll learn
from Rizwan Ansari VP of product and
design dats endo so who will guide you
to apply your skills to a real-world
project you will build a monetization
model for a post revenue b2b
software-as-a-service business and then
come up with hypotheses about potential
changes to the monetization strategy get
early access to this course in the
upcoming growth product manager nano
degree program and get a head start on
mastering monetization strategy for your
business and product today